el futuro de bakú de esa población en el
centro del Don básque lleva siendo
asediada por las tropas rusas desde el
pasado verano Y que ha sido tal vez la
batalla más importante más Sangrienta de
todas las que se han dado desde la
invasión a escala máxima el pasado
veinticuatro de febrero sigue dando de
que hablar después de que hoy el
fundador de esas fuerzas paramilitares
Wagner que están liderando la lucha por
el portmut asegurar aquellos tenían ya
el control del este del país y esto es
entendible o explicado según algunas
organizaciones que siguen la guerra como
el instituto de estudios de la guerra
con sede en Washington después de la
explosión de dos puentes por parte de
los ucranianos uno de ellos que comunica
con el este lo que permitía que las
tropas ucranianas se fueran
retrocediendo estratégicamente para
controlar el centro de la ciudad y el
oeste que todavía tienen Bajo su control
hoy también o anoche hablaba el
presidente
con la cadena estadounidense tienen y se
aseguraba que seguirían luchando por
bakmut a una ciudad que consideraban
estratégica y él decía que si la perdían
esto daría paso una nueva ofensiva rusa
para termar el control de ciudades mucho
más estratégicas en el don vast como lo
son kramators y eslovens que hoy también
hablaba el secretario general de la otan
que decía que bakmut eventualmente podía
caer sin embargo rescataba que
muchísimas fuerzas rusas y muchísimo
armamento ha sido destruido durante esta
batalla y por eso decía que es
importantísimo según seguir dando apoyo
a Ucrania que como digo sigue luchando
por el don vas por el Back mood
especialmente se les dijo que se había
reunido con sus generales y que había
sido una decisión tomada entre todos